[Evans] I think there are 3 main themes that really pervade the course
that we've seen over and over again,
but I haven't mentioned them explicitly until now.
These are themes that aren't just pervasive throughout this course
but are pervasive throughout all computer science.
The first one is abstraction.
Abstraction is all about hiding details.
The point of abstraction is to make it so you can have 1 thing that is used
in many different ways, and you can use it
without necessarily understanding all the details behind it.
We've seen lots and lots of examples of abstraction in this class.
The most important one is procedural abstraction.
We can write 1 procedure, use it to do lots of different things
depending on what the inputs are, and when we use that procedure
we don't need to know exactly what sequence of instructions will execute.
What we know is what the procedure does.
The second main theme is universality.
We talked about this early in the class
about how computers are universal machines.
I want to show you how much better I've gotten at drawing.
If you thought my drawing of a toaster in Unit 1 was not recognizable,
I hope you can see how much better I can do now.
This is a toaster, and a toaster is very different from a computer.
A computer is a universal machine.
We've seen lots of examples of how a computer is universal--
that we only need a few simple constructs to be able to define every possible program.
We saw that if we had a way to make decisions--
and we saw we have that with if in Python;
we saw that if we have a way to keep track of things--
and in Python we can do that using variables and data;
and if we have a way to keep going--
and we first saw that using while--with a while loop we can make something keep going
as long as we want.
But in fact, we don't even need while.
We could do that with procedures, and that's what we saw with recursive definitions
in Unit 6.
Once we have those 3 things, we can write any computer program.
So we have much more power with a computer than we do with a toaster.
The final major theme I want to summarize as our third main theme
is one we've already mentioned here.
It's recursive definitions.
We introduced those explicitly in Unit 6,
but you saw them many times before that.
The first time you saw them was actually in Unit 1.
We saw these rules that said we can make an expression
by taking another expression, using the plus operator,
and combining it with another expression.
That was not enough by itself for a recursive definition.
We also needed a base case.
We saw a base case, like we can have an expression that's a number.
So the big idea here is that with very simple rules we can define infinitely many things
and very complex things by using rules to define things
in terms of simpler versions of themselves.